he's a rat because he didn't want to  deal with the crimes he had other people  do for him he paid other people he paid  him it has nothing to do with gang he  they didn't do it for free that's how  much they didn't respect him they he  charged him if i called my homeboy to do  something they going to do it for me  period and i wouldn't call him right  right right right he paid them he was a  criminal before them he'll be a criminal  after them right now he's a he's a  working informant like i'm looking at  the stuff 21 savage and i'm doing  talking about fighting this man what are  y'all thinking man this man will get you  put in prison  right now  this ain't over you don't just snitch  one time on on the case that big and get  that little time he's a permanent  informant he's going to tell for 20 or  30 years that man is a rat wack no here  right everybody know you're right